there are many many proofs that a  squared plus b squared is equal to c  squared this is a neat proof from the  yukti Basha also known as the world's  first calculus textbook we have two  squares with side lengths equal to a and  b  the total area of the two squares is  equal to a squared plus b squared  now let's rearrange the areas  construct two triangles with sides of a  and b as shown and let each triangle's  hypotenuse be equal to C  rotate each triangle 90 degrees from its  leftmost vertex to construct a square  with side length equal to C  this square has area c squared and  clearly its area is the same as the  original two squares therefore a squared  plus b squared is equal to c squared